comment vous allez ça se passe bien
aujourd'hui tout va bien cette période
de fin d'année hors jeu s'est pas plaint
on met en place je sais pas peut-être
que d'aller regarder cette vidéo si
c'est plutôt fin d'année et au début
d'année prochaine plutôt milieu d'année
prochaine
dans tous les cas j'espère que vous
allez bien dites moi comment ça se passe
pour vous en bas en commentaire
aujourd'hui de vous parler d'un sujet
qui est un peu différent je veux vous
parler de vous de votre argent d'une
application qui va vous aider à faire
des économies
je sais pas vous mais en tout cas moi ce
qui me concerne j'ai eu beaucoup de mal
pendant des années la faire des
économies à me dire ok j'ai mon budget
tous les mois et il faut que je mette un
petit quelque chose de côté que ce soit
pour construire un projet c'est un
appartement que ce soit pour acheter un
vélo pour partir en vacances ou tout
simplement pour avoir un peu d'argent
pour faire des cadeaux à noël donc
l'idée de mettre de l'argent de côté et
récurrents et j'ai jamais été très très
bon là dedans mais il existe aujourd'hui
une application qui est intéressante et
qui va vous permettre de faire ça pour
vous sans vous en rendre compte de façon
complètement automatisée sans pour
autant faire n'importe quoi cette
application s'appelle plume plumeplume
djoum et qui va vous permettre de mettre
de l'argent de côté extrêmement
facilement c'est effectivement une vidéo
qui a réalisé en partenariat avec lui
quand ils m'ont contacté ils m'ont dit
monsieur grenet une solution qui est
extrêmement pertinente pour permettre de
mettre de l'argent de côté ça peut
permettre d'aider pas mal de monde
puisque nous sommes dans une situation
économique qui est pas hyper évident on
va pas forcément pensé à mettre de
l'argent de côté
quels que soient les projets qu'on veut
réaliser avec grâce à votre application
vous allez pouvoir venir personnaliser
la manière dont vous souhaitez mettre de
l'argent de côté vous allez pouvoir le
paramétrer dès le départ le faire
évoluer par la suite si vous le
souhaitez mais vous définissez une règle
de base c'est très simple c'est
transparent et bien évidemment votre
argent reste disponible pour vous
puissiez le récupérer quand vous
souhaitez quand on parle d'argent on
parle toujours d'un sujet qui est un peu
délicat parce qu'on se dit ok mon argent
je sais pas où est ce qu'ils valent et
je sais pas quelle manière cela va
fonctionner est-ce que c'est dangereux
est ce que c'est pas dangereux est ce
que je risque de me faire avoir ou par
plume c'est une entreprise qui existe
depuis 2010 est elle est basée en
angleterre et elle s'inscrit dans cette
tendance
de nouvelles entreprises qui viennent
vous aider à gérer votre argent et il ya
plus d'un million d'utilisateurs sur
pelouse l'entreprise y est tout juste
d'arriver en france pour vous proposer
cette nouvelle solution nous explique
comment ça marche c'est très simple vous
avez votre application leur smartphone
je vous la montrer dans quelques
instants
ce que vous allez faire tout d'abord
c'est que vous allez vous inscrire
facilement vous en douterez quelques
petites informations nom prénom adresse
et compagnie ensuite il
falloir un lier votre compte bancaire de
votre banque à plum
alors rassurez vous tout est extrêmement
sécurisé mois qui suit le numéro un de
la paranoïa dès qu'il s'agit de toucher
à mes comptes bancaires que vous êtes
sûr que j'ai les pieds je reverrai tg
d'arrivée 15 fois plus me va passer par
un service tiers qui a une api qui
complètement sécurisé permet de
récupérer les écritures de votre compte
bancaire et vous allez vous autoriser
l'application cloud à pouvoir prélever
de l'argent sur votre compte
alors soyez rassurés y'a pas prélever
n'importe quoi il a prélevé uniquement
ce que vous lui autoriser prélevé selon
les paramètres que vous allez prédéfinir
doc dans tous les cas ils ne vont pas
faire n'importe quoi arrive votre argent
et c'est vous qui garder le contrôle en
toute circonstance puisque dans les
questions de sécurité ici vous allez le
déverrouiller avec des empreintes
biométriques ici ça va être facile dit
qu'à permettre de le déverrouiller et
derrière il ya un cryptage tls 256 bits
et si toutefois vous rencontrez un
problème bien service client qui est
disponible 7 jours sur 7 et vos données
ne sont absolument pas partagé en dehors
de tout à l'heure actuelle comme le
service vient d'arriver en france vous
avez quelques bancs de disponible banque
populaire bnp paribas caisse d'epargne
crédit agricole crédit mutuel
hello bank et la société générale la
liste va augmenter dans les mois à venir
comment ça marche tout ça ça marche de
différentes manières la première chose
loomba bord accès à vos dépenses et un
bond rentrées d'argent il va analyser
toutes vos transactions au quotidien
pour bien transférer une somme d'argent
de votre compte bancaire vers votre
compte poule qui sera votre compte
d'épargné et ce de manière totalement
automatique et transparente
une fois de plus c'est vous garder la
main mise à dessus et vous pouvez
récupérer l'argent à tout moment
l'application c'est celle là dans votre
application vous avez accès à un tableau
de bord vous avez différentes manières
pour venir mettre de l'argent de côté
il ya automatique arrondi il ya d'autres
services que je montrerai dans quelques
instants on va râler sur l'huile en
premier c'est le mode automatique alors
le mode automatique il est assez
intéressant parce que d'avenir analyser
vos revenus et vos dépenses
il vous evans algorithmes derrière qui
va mettre de l'argent de côté pour vous
alors ça c'est bien mais en fait vous
allez pouvoir décider vous de quelle
manière ça va être fait en fonction de
votre mood là je suis sur un mode normal
donc il va le faire un peu classiquement
si je met plus d'argent et bien coûter
voyez je peux mettre 25 % de plus avec
le mode david ambitieux 50% de plus ou
alors carrément le mode beast
après si je veux mettre un petit peu
moins je le match ils 25% d'économies r
- nous alors carrément timide comme ça
j'y vais mollo mollo il ya un autre
moyen de dire économiser de l'argent
lorsque vous à lignières faire un achat
par exemple vous achetez pour 2 euros 75
je ne sais quoi et bien lui va bien
faire un arrondi à l'euro supérieur
c'est-à-dire la différence entre les 2
euros 75 et 3 euros donc soit 25
centimes qui vont être mis de côté en
épargne et ça sur toutes les opérations
que vous allez faire vous pouvez bien
évidemment faire le choix de l'activer
ou de ne pas l'activer
mais c'est une manière de mettre
quelques centimes de côté et tout ça mis
bout à bout vous permet de vous créer
une épargne et si je le souhaite je peux
venir carrément activer les super
arrondi notre option qui est assez sympa
c'est l'option jour de paye il va venir
mettre de l'argent dès que j'aurai reçu
mon salaire je vais décider l'argent que
je veux qu'ils mettent de côté moi j'en
sais rien par exemple jour de paille et
bien tu vas mettre son ego de côté
je vais définir le jour parce qu'on
n'est pas tous payer la même manière il
y en a qui vont être payé le 30 mai qui
vont être payé le 2 le 5 le dise vous
choisissez l'adapt qui vous arrange le
mieux comme ça c'est extrêmement
pratique
une autre option qui est assez marrante
ses jours pluvieux dès qu'il pleut chez
vous est bien une somme va être mise de
côté pour votre épargne autant vous dire
que vous allez économiser beaucoup plus
d'argent si vous habitez à dunkerque que
si vous habitez à marseille autre option
qui est très sympa c'est le défi 52
semaines première semaine vous mettez un
euro deux côtés deuxième semaine 2 euros
troisième semaine 3 euros et ça jusqu'à
la fin de l'année
ça vous fera au total 1300 78 euros
d'épargné grâce à cette technique
pendant un an voyez c'est une façon
assez maligne d'automatiser votre
épargne par différentes manières que ce
soit de l'épargné directement lorsque
vous allez toucher votre salaire que ce
soit des arrondis supérieur que vous
laissiez l'algorithme de choisir
automatiquement la meilleure sommes à
mettre de côté il ya plusieurs façons de
venir paramétrer son départ je trouve ça
assez malin c'est transparent
une fois de plus prévenir le réajusté en
fonction de vos besoins si vous trouvez
que ça y paraît un peu trop ou pas assez
vous venez le régler vous venez de
paramétrer et une fois de plus c'est
vous qui avez l'âme a misé dessus et
c'est vous qui pouvez récupérer votre
argent
quand vous souhaitez toulouse est en
train d'arriver en france ils vont
proposer d'un service très prochainement
notamment vous permet de pouvoir faire
des investissements avec l'argent que
vous avez deux côtés vous allez pouvoir
investir à partir de 1 euro dans de très
nombreuses entreprises comme facebook
google ou bien encore apple ça c'est un
service qui est très populaire en
angleterre
alors attention ici est toujours une
part de risque il faut vraiment le
savoir est également et vous permettront
de
connaître le montant vous dépensez pour
vos factures ils vous diront si vous
payez un peu trop cher et vous
proposeront une alternative une fois de
plus attention ici à bien vérifier que
vous aurez la même qualité de service
afin que vous payez vraiment pour
exactement la même chose
la plupart des services sont gratuits
vous avez quelques options payantes qui
vous coûteront aux deux euros par mois
on va l'essayer pendant 30 jours
et vous pouvez l'annuler à tout moment
pendant les 30 jours d'essai ça vous
permettra notamment d'avoir des pocket
par exemple ici j'ai rarement pocket de
base j'ai mis 10 euros pour l'instant
dessus de l'argent au cas où
et ensuite j'ai créé un pocket pour mes
vacances vous pouvez créer un pocket
pour acheter un vélo pour tout ce que
vous voulez pour créer autant de pocket
que vous voulez et vous choisissez de
quelle manière vous voulez votre argent
soit réparti entre vos différents pocket
comme ça vous garder la mainmise sur la
répartition de votre argent et vous avez
également un service de cashback qui
vous permettra de récupérer une partie
de l'argent que vous avez dépensé auprès
des partenaires de plume notamment vous
voyez booking 6% regroupe 8 25% c'est
très précis hotels.com 2 3 à 4 5 % ici
vous n'allez pas venir vous enrichir en
faisant des économies vous allez pas
avoir 3000 4000 euros qui vont arriver
sur notre compte comme ça on parle bien
évidemment de votre argent de votre
capacité à générer des économies avec
l'argent que vous touchez pour moi le
fait que vous allez réussir à mettre de
l'argent de côté grâce à plum
c'est vraiment de positionner le bon
curseur pour ça vous permettre de mettre
de l'argent de côté sans que ça vous
prive au quotidien que vous aviez une
gestion malines de vos économies
l'arrondi supérieur c'est vraiment malin
le fait de laisser l'algorithme calculé
pour vous c'est aussi malin tout en
venant régler une fois de plus le
curseur de 25% en 25% l'idée le plum
c'est de le laisser travailler sur
plusieurs années on vous permet vraiment
de cumuler une grosse cagnotte
vous laissez donc travailler en tâche de
fond vous ne regardez pas vous y allez
temps en temps et vous verrez qu'au bout
d'un moment ça finit par payer
surtout que nous sommes dans une période
qui est pas hyper simple pas hyper
évidente avec cette crise actuelle donc
une solution comme plum
j'approuve extrêmement intéressante je
vous invite à cliquer sur le lien dans
la description pour télécharger plume et
commence à faire des économies très
facilement dites moi vous ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire qu'est ce
que vous pensez de ce système
d'application qui vous permet de mettre
de l'argent de côté extrêmement
facilement ce que ça vous paraît bien
pas bien judicieux pas judicieux marquis
matou sable évidemment on bat en
commentaire et quant à nous on se
retrouve extrêmement rapidement pour
continuer à parler tech
gros bisous et après ciao
[Musique]